welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode
50. hopefully i'm getting more
comfortable i can't believe i've done
50 of these i had the pleasure of
interviewing tucker max in this episode
i remember reading blogs he'd written
and one of his books in college
and when he agreed to come on i was kind
of like really you're into that
but it was a fantastic conversation
tucker max has had multiple books on the
new york times bestsellers list
i'm writing a book and thought maybe
there's something i can learn here
my book's going to be a bit different
than his but still
multiple bestsellers he has a family now
and we spoke about that
we talked about one of his very
successful businesses scribe
that helped publish david goggins book
we spoke about growing up
accepting responsibility and the
consequences his first books brought on
his life and why he wrote them in the
first place
we covered psychedelic therapies and
learning about past trauma and much more
it was really interesting i thought it
would be good to mention self-authoring
in this episode
given what we cover about writing
self-authoring is a suite of exercises
that my dad spent 30 years developing
that helps people organize their
thoughts and map out a life plan with
steps so they know where they want to go
i found it immensely helpful in avoiding
futures i don't want
particularly when i was younger and more
foolish but also now
it keeps me on track if you're going
through something intense a divorce a
new relationship
kids a new job being fired it can be
really useful to help you look at
opportunity
self authoring.com code mp for 15
off which i think makes it 25 dollars in
total it's an absolute steal for how
well it helps you organize your future
for
you and sort out your past self
authoring.com
code mp for 15 off and remember to check
out my clips channel
linked in the pinned comment or you can
search michaela peterson clips on
youtube
we have short clips from podcasts in
there if you enjoy the episode
please subscribe and leave me a review
have a good week
[Music]
tucker max welcome to my podcast thank
you thanks for having me michaela
uh i'm very excited to be speaking with
you i read
one of your books i hope they say i hope
they serve
beer in hell when i was i think i must
have been in the last year of
high school or starting university and i
remember being
i remember laughing a lot and being
mildly horrified at the same time
but it was really funny um
so i i came across you because i was
somehow i came across scribe you're
you've you've co-founded this company
scribe yeah we did david goggins books
yeah we found
a bunch of big ones yeah so so i'm i
want to talk a little bit about that
because i i was going through the
website and i thought that sounds like
that sounds really useful for people uh
especially people who maybe aren't the
greatest at writing but have a really
interesting story
uh and then i was kind of caught between
i'll get you to describe what it is but
i was caught between well
is it cheating or is it just a smarter
way to do things
and i was thinking about it and then i
saw that you'd done you know how you'd
help with david goggins book and i was
like wow this is like why didn't i know
about this
and then it said you know co-founded by
tucker max and i was like ah
huh so can we can we start off i've got
a bunch to talk about but can we start
off by
talking about scribe a little bit yeah
so
the the the company started basically
six years ago i was in an entrepreneur
dinner and this woman
like a very well-known entrepreneur very
successful she has a family a business
she's like i've been trying her people
been asking me to write a book for 10
years and i haven't been able to do it
because
i have all these other things going on
she's like how do i get this book out of
my head
and so i looked at her and i'm like are
you asking me how to write a book
without writing
and she's like yeah kind of and then so
i was such i gave her the worst
most elitist snobby writer answer which
was something to be effective like well
everyone wants to uh you know be a star
but no one wants to put in the work and
i started
lecturing her about hard work like i
know right i know it's the worst
and so she politely listened to me for
about five minutes
and then she rolled her eyes pretty much
out of her skull
and he was like tucker this is an
entrepreneur dinner are you an
entrepreneur
and i'm like yeah of course and she's
like no i don't think so because a real
entrepreneur would help me solve my
problem
and not lecture me about hard work and i
was like
oh [ __ ] because she was totally right
you know when someone calls you out and
they're just
right and there's nothing else to say
and so of course i became obsessed with
this idea
um and then it hit me like two months
later because it i'm slow it takes me a
while
that this is a solved problem it's been
solved for 2000 years
scribes literally have been writing down
the thoughts and words of people for
thousands of years we we know uh
about socrates because of plato you know
we know i mean go down the list we know
marco polo's journey because his
cellmate when he because he was in debt
his cellmate when he got back to venice
was described like we can go down the
list
of most of the famous figures or many of
western
civilization especially had scribes i
was like why can't i just do this for
her
and so i just kind of did it with her um
as like uh honestly because i got called
out and i was like all right i gotta
make sure i
you know i make this right and we wrote
this great book and it was fantastic and
i know how to
write books and publish books it was
easy for me and so then she's like um
she literally was like when i tell my
friends about this
uh what do you want me to tell them you
charge because i charge her like just a
little bit of money
way less than i would charge someone to
ghostwrite a book because i wanted to
see if i could do this
and and i was like why would you tell
your friend why would you tell your
friends about this
yeah and she looked to be like what are
you dumb she's like be
when i refer people so you can do more
i'm like i don't want to do this again
it's like what are you talking about and
of course i'm such an idiot i'm the
worst entrepreneur because like it
literally didn't even occur to me that
there was something else here
and so she's like okay well i'm just
gonna tell him and she like named this
number that was obscenely low and i'm
like okay whatever
so she started sending me people and i'm
like i'm not gonna do this
i had a friend of mine who was a decent
writer at the time and was
i was working with him some other
projects i was like do you want to do
these
projects i'm like we'll just split them
on he's like yeah he's canadian actually
zach he's from toronto
and so he started doing this and then
after about two months we had we'd done
like a quarter million dollars of
business he's like dude i think we have
a company here
and i'm like yeah you might be right and
so we
started off mainly just kind of like
essentially an alternative to
ghostwriting like we interview you
we get your ideas out of your head and
your words and your voice
and uh whereas ghostwriting usually is
like somewhat you pay someone a bunch of
money and then they write a book and you
put your name on it right
you could argue whether they're
different but we really did like create
a very distinct
almost algorithmic process for getting
words for interviewing someone and
getting their ideas
out of their head and then it really
just grew from there right that's where
we started
now um the company is
man we're 60 full-time and 200 part-time
and we've done
750 published books and we've got
another
thousand plus in process now and a
couple massive books like
tiffany haddish's book last black
unicorn david goggins book can't hurt me
um a bunch of others like that dan
sullivan's book who not how
um a bunch and and we do all services
now so
whether it's writing publishing
marketing
um we do all of it uh yeah i mean that's
why like coggins came to us for
everything he did writing publishing and
marketing for us
but a lot of people like nissim celeb um
he came to west and we published his
last book and we of course we didn't do
any writing he doesn't need anyone's
help writing in fact
part of his deal was don't touch a word
in the manuscript i send you
and i was like are you sure to sim
because you have a lot of errors in here
and he's like no no
i want the errors i want feedback from
my audience and we're like okay people
are going to get pissed and he's like
that's fine
and so we didn't touch a word and um and
so we've become
for a lot of people an alternative to
traditional publishing
um i mean i don't have to tell you and
your father dealt with all kinds of
issues with traditional publishing like
i know i went through the same stuff
and so there wasn't an alternative
really a really high level
company that did absolute a plus work
but would have the opposite business
model traditional where you pay fee for
service
and then you own all the rights and
royalties but you still get top-notch
distribution top-notch book covers
everything
and so we kind of everyone calls it
professional publishing now because it's
self-publishing is like do it yourself
and then traditional is like they own
everything
there's never really been a true in the
middle option
um and uh that's really what we are and
the niche is called professional
publishing
professional publishing okay i've been
looking into self-publishing because
you know the benefit of going with a big
publishing house
from the little bit i know is
diminishing
it's gone basically yeah almost no
reason
unless you can if you can get a massive
advance there might
maybe you go with them maybe but uh
like we can do everything we actually do
everything better
than traditional publishers like in
terms of writing
they don't do any writing or writing
help but in terms of book covers
things like that they use they all use
the same set of freelancers that we use
and our those same free seriously
they're all freelancers
and they actually do better work for us
because we
pay more and we pay on time you'd be
shocked
like that i could tell you stories not
that you care but like
we have uh uh uh uh book cover designers
who are like
penguin random house still owes me 30
grand
and they're 120 days late on payment we
pay
half up front and half on finish every
time
all the time so they love us and they
give us their best
work and then also we got to remember
we're in the service business like if
you were a client
you pay us you know 30 grand or 40 grand
or 50 grand
and you're paying us whereas penguin
random house right just for example
you're not paying them they're paying
you so they look at you as an employee
they don't really care about you because
they can replace you with almost
unless you're you know barack obama or
james patterson or one of the
very few people selling tens of millions
of books they can replace you
like that they don't care their only
clients really are bookstores they don't
even
think about it penguin doesn't even sell
to they don't sell to readers
they don't amazon sells to readers
barnes and noble sells to readers right
like whoever
uh local bookstores their only clients
really are distributors
and so that's a and and obviously as we
all know now
uh the the social status they get
amongst their friends
those are the only two things that they
actually care about uh and so whereas we
care about servicing the client who's
the author
yeah it's interesting because it's hard
to tell how much
being a published author with some of
these companies is worth saying penguin
published you
and it's certainly it's certainly worth
something
but is it worth it yeah it depends who
it depends on the publisher
well here's the if you want status with
old line media
who are gatekeepers trying to control
the narrative
then going with a random house might
make sense right if you're an academic
if you work in media if you're a
politician
then that you're buying status you're
saying i'm chosen by the right people
right
whereas like goggins [ __ ] hated those
people right he didn't want to go with
them
and so because he he he couldn't stand
that snobbiness
and that elitism and the [ __ ] like
think about it like
he got a 300 000 offer from harper
harper one i think it was
and and i i remember him talking to me
on the phone he's like
why the [ __ ] would i give them my life
rights for 300 grand i'm like i don't
know dude that's why i started this
company
it's why i do my own stuff like i and
he's like
oh yeah you're totally right like i'm
going with you guys this is great and
you can ask david like uh
he he can't say enough great things
about us and what we've done
i'll give you in fact i don't know if
i've ever talked about these numbers
publicly i'll talk about them on your
podcast because dave is cool with it
he's sold let me give you approximate
numbers because i have to look him up to
get
precise but he sold about 2.5 million
copies of his books
in all mediums do you know what you know
what he would have if he'd gone with
harper he would have you know he would
have made good money he would have made
about
i think six million yeah about that
right yeah do you know what he's made
with us
how much 2.5 million sales 20
million so more than 3x
close to 3.5 x so you can make
if you're david you can make 6 million
or you can make
20 million that's
incredible mm-hmm now granted david's
look david's an outlier not many people
sell 2.5 million books right that's an
extreme like me i've sold that mini more
your dad sold that many but there are
very few people who are at that level
but even at the lower levels
not only are you going to make more
money you get to control your book
you get to make all creative choices
which you do not
uh if you are with traditional and you
get to decide
everything how it's marketed what you do
how you're represented
you have full control you make way more
money
almost everything's better unless you're
trying to buy status and even then just
with a small group of people
right like a lot of people like oh i
think it's important who published it
uh my book and i'll ask them what's your
favorite book and they'll say
you know whatever it doesn't matter
they'll say uh oh i love
glenn and doyle's new book i'm like okay
cool who published it and they're like
oh yeah you're right i have no idea
right because no reader knows
no one cares yeah okay well no and yeah
it's very it's very interesting uh what
what do you guys use as
tricks to sell stories like how do you
know when you're interviewing somebody
because people can get caught up from
say trauma past trauma and then they can
go into
way too much detail about certain
aspects of their life that the reader
isn't going to be interested in and they
have no idea that the reader isn't going
to be interested in
so how do you know how to make a story
that's readable and interesting
well we know how the question is can we
help our authors get there
right so those are two very different
questions it's
really easy and not really easy but
look everyone in my company who works in
story
like the writers the editors etc are all
decades they've been doing this for
decades right so we hire people who are
you know we're not bless their hearts
because they're amazing at certain
things but we're not hiring um
filipino va's to be our writers right
like they're incredible at other things
but
the people we hire for writers all have
a long long list
decades of experience and at that point
you know how to tell a story and you
know what story is going to work
it's easy for us to know what's often
hard is is
teaching this to authors right now if
we're doing uh sort of the scribe method
and
we're just calling ghost writing because
that's what most people think if we're
helping them write the book
through an interview process then
generally honestly michaela it becomes
in a lot of ways a therapy session
like we have to let people talk if
they're doing memoir and if they're
doing non-fiction it's really easy like
if you're
like like this book who not how this is
dan sullivan he's probably the best
entrepreneur coach in the world
this book is basically uh about the way
i
think to think who should do a job not
how do you do it right and so it's a way
for entrepreneurs to understand
not just delegation but really kind of
expand their thinking
he like that's not you don't have to
worry that much about them just talking
endlessly about themselves
yeah because you can bring them back and
say okay who's your avatar
oh it's an entrepreneur do they care
about this yes or no right and so you
can generally get them back in
in prescriptive non-fiction really
quickly and easily memoir is different
memoir is a whole
different game yeah well so i'll tell
you what we generally do
is that we we both coach this and you
know we have
big extensive coaching programs where
people write their own books and we tell
them how and then kind of guide them
through weekly calls and all that stuff
or we have it where we do it with them
or for them
if we're doing it for them it's
generally a matter of like
it's like a therapeutic process let them
talk let them get out what they want to
get out and then we come back to
okay what needs to go in the book right
and that's that's just time if they're
writing it themselves it's a similar
process what we teach them to do
is like if you're it's a great example
if they're going
telling a traumatic story the best thing
they can do
is we call it a vomit draft so in your
first drafts we'll tell you
just dump it all on the page everything
vomit everything out you want to say
emotionally vomit
all of it out right there's because the
worst thing you can do in a creative
stage
is edit right because the editing mind
and the creative mind are quite
literally different parts of the brain
and they work differently
and so uh we tell them that's actually
the hard part is
getting them to give themselves
permission to just put everything down
and let go
and not try and edit and not try and
self-censor
once we get them there then usually it
becomes
like a flood a torrent right and it's
okay just
torrent it out right and they'll end up
with anywhere from
60 to 200 000 words a lot of times on a
memoir
then we have them go back and and
they'll
what they'll what almost always what
happens is memoir is that people start
writing
for one reason and then realize through
the writing process it becomes a
discovery process
and so they really realize oh i thought
i was going to tell this story but
this is actually the story i'm trying to
tell and so then we teach them how to go
back through their first draft and
pull out what the actual story find the
story pull it out and then cut the like
take the rest and leave it somewhere
else and just tell the story
that they're trying to tell and the key
with that is
you we tell people you write for
yourself
but you edit for your reader right so
you can be completely self-indulgent as
you write
and completely uh free but then come
back
and think of who's my reader and it's a
simple question why are they going to
care
right or are they going to care and so
like you
i mean god knows i've done this i've
written stories that i thought were just
complete genius and then came back to
him and realized
no one's going to care about me this is
just a story about how clever i am
and no one cares like what people care
about in memoir
what we always tell people is no one's
going to read your memoir to learn about
you
they're going to read your memoir to
learn about themselves
and the only way they learn about
themselves is by having by you being
honest and authentic and real and raw
and discovering uncovering and telling
the true story of your life
because that's a mirror back on them
that they can then learn about
themselves does that make sense
yeah that makes sense you need to have
lessons in there not just
stories about what happened to you no
actually we we tell people in memoir
the last thing you should do is put a
lesson in no seriously because then it
turns the energy
out away from from yourself and about
the reader
right and also like if you're looking
for a lesson you're not
stopping and thinking about you're not
stopping and feeling your life
you're thinking constantly right so it's
so funny the memoir algorithm
is the easiest thing there is what
happened
like if you want to write a memoir
there's only two questions what happened
how did you feel about it then what
happened how did you feel about that
and then what happened and how did you
feel about that now you can insert if
you learned a lesson cool
you can put that in and if you thought
something cool you can put that in
but that's those are additions only
where they are appropriate
but if you want to write a great memoir
the instructions are as simple as
what happened and how did you feel
that's it that's all you're actually
writing think about
all the great memoirs the iconic western
memoir to me in in the entire western
canon is probably the diary of anne
frank
and like a 14 year old jewish girl
living in an attic in amsterdam wrote
the greatest
memoir of all time and all she did was
talk about what happened and how she
felt
and nothing else and but she did it in
such a pure
honest way she wasn't trying to be
anything
she wasn't showing off she wasn't
pretending
it was the only play the reason so great
is because it was the place
she felt she could be her honest self
and any memoir that gets even close to
that
tends to do really really well yeah
i suppose you wouldn't want to tell
people lessons you'd rather say this is
what i learned
potentially or have them or infer it
right so that they can come to that
conclusion themselves you don't want to
be
throwing these things at people in in a
memoir if it's a self-help
in a memoir right if it's a self-help
book then it's like hey i'm going to
teach you how to make money or i'm going
to teach you how to feel happy it's like
cool tell me what to do
but a memoir is tell me what you did
yeah so you have okay that's that
answers most of my questions about
scribe i thought that was
genius i hadn't heard i've heard of
ghost writing obviously but
you come across some ghost written books
and you can you can
tell but the idea of interviewing
somebody who either doesn't have time or
isn't going to be able to organize their
thoughts properly and then taking their
words and putting it into a book
is incredibly valuable it's a good idea
it's done it's a it might
the compliment i like the best is um
when friends of mine are people i know
or whatever will be like how the hell do
like i've read four books i love them
all
and i didn't realize until i got to the
acknowledgements that you guys were
involved i'm like
right exactly that's the point is that a
great scribe
shouldn't show up in the process we
should be in the background
yeah okay okay moving on
um let's let's actually switch topics a
little bit
so you you wrote you basically came up
with the genre
fratire and that was basically your ask
your escapades of being young and like
college escapades and then you kind of
segued into
family life so was that
like was that switch something planned
was it difficult or was it age related
like what happened
uh okay well so the the the joke i
always make is
um you know you you played with
g.i joes or barbies when you were you
know four and you didn't when you were
18 and no one thinks that's weird right
but i always get the question of like
well you used to drink and act like an
idiot and now you're a responsible
family man how could that happen i'm
like
doesn't everyone go through that the
only difference between me and most
people
is that i wrote down everything i did
and i used my real name
and i stood up and spoke truth about it
and that's it and no one had ever done
that
about the things that i was talking
about in my generation right like
other people have written about doing
drugs and acting like an idiot
uh god knows that's a whole genre but
like
no one in my generation who was like me
had done that i really and not the way i
had done it right and so
it was like it was crazy there was 10
years where it was like that was
the thing i mean my beer in hell was on
the bestseller list the new york times
to sell this i think for six consecutive
years yeah that's insane
i mean it was ridiculous um well so
here's the thing i started writing at
27.
literally i began my writing career at
27.
um i uh was done
i finished my last book of frat tire
which by the way i did not name that
genre i hate that name because i wasn't
in a fraternity
i was i wasn't in a fraternity is a
problem and my books aren't satire
they're memoirs yeah i know they're not
satire so that's a problem yeah
the funny part is that of course the new
york times is the one who said that i'm
like it's typical new york times is to
like
like name it something that we're
neither it's a portmanteau and neither
of the words that are supposed to be
represented are actually true but um uh
i started at 27 and i finished at 35
and i turned and i retired at the end of
my last book before i even
i hadn't met my current wife i wasn't
even i was years away from meeting her
and i wrote at the end of the book i'm
like listen i i am done
drinking all the time and hooking up and
acting like a
a foolish you know 25 year old because
i'm not that age anymore and
it's just not interesting to me and it
wasn't like one of those things where
uh you know i was like oh i was a
horrible person and i beg forgiveness no
[ __ ] that i mean i did some dumb things
i shouldn't have done definitely
but like i i'm super happy uh with
with at least the overall ark arcane
trajectory i'm glad i went through that
phase it's what got me here
right um it was just like i just don't
feel like doing that anymore i don't
feel like
when i was 27 i wanted nothing more in
the world than to go out
have fun with my friends drink and hook
up with girls
the idea now of going out my friends and
drinking beer is like oh
god cause i can think about it as the
hangover and how tedious it would be
and like like oh yeah i deal with my
kids the next day and they're gonna
they're gonna be up at 6 30 no matter
what i was doing the night before and
they're gonna want
oatmeal and eggs and bacon and so i'm
gonna and so it's like uh
i just didn't feel like doing any of
that anymore and so i literally i
retired
from the genre i stopped writing those
books and i had plenty of money
i had nothing else i had to do and so i
i
honestly i didn't do a whole lot for a
while i invested in some tech companies
did pretty well ended up doing really
well
and like um i kind of i don't want to
say it did nothing
it was almost like i had to recover it
probably took me honestly straight up
two or three years to just get out of
the public eye
and sit down and chill for a while and
relax
and let my neurological system
decompress
and like um it was i do i
i didn't realize until i started
psychedelic medicine not even therapy
but it took psychedelic medicine for me
to really realize how much trauma i went
through in those 10 years
like how how hard that was on me
um both the things i did to myself and
the things that were done to me
and and the combination it was brutally
intense
and so i think i started therapy about
yeah i started i stopped writing about
34-35
i think i started therapy right after
almost like
two months after i turned in my last
book or i published my last book
and then it was like it was honestly
just like
i knew i wanted a wife and i knew i
wanted kids and i knew i wanted a family
i had no idea when or how that was going
to come i wasn't worried about it like i
i i knew that would happen the the goal
for me was
i had to get right first i had to heal
myself first and i thought it was mainly
healing myself from childhood stuff
yeah i had a lot of stuff to deal with
there but before i could get there i had
to get through what i had just been
through in the last decade and
it was not fun it was hard and a lot of
it was owning my own stuff like i had to
own my shadow so to speak i'd be like
okay dude
like yeah yeah all this bad stuff
happened to you but how much did you
bring on yourself how much did you court
how much
did you uh fan those flames i'm like
yeah pretty much all of it and uh yeah
that's not easy
no it was not it was not fun and so it
was not it was not like
i stopped writing and then married the
next girl i met and then now i have kids
like my kids are young my kids are six
four and eighteen months
and oh my god i know i got tiny little
one
yes yeah and then we got i think
probably another one we'll see
but another one's we're definitely gonna
have four so if either the the fourth is
on the way or it will be soon
so even though i'm 45 like like i'm
like the place most guy dads are in
their 30s like
like my development it's like i had a
missing decade in terms of life because
that was spent
like fame you know fame sucks that time
out of you and it's
gone and it's like oh [ __ ] now i gotta
catch back up on everything you know
yeah i don't know if that answers your
question sorry that was a little bit
rare it does
no no that was good there's two things i
want to follow up from there so you
you briefly mentioned psychedelics and
i've
found them immensely helpful so when you
talk about
therapy are you talking about like
talking to someone back and forth or is
this like
psychedelic therapy both so so i'm a big
believer that um
in the psychedelic therapeutic space
it's the psychological medicine space
anyone who has any experience with those
medicines will tell you
that the medicines do not heal you the
medicines
open up a space for you to do your own
healing
right and i think talk therapy is one
and what they'll say
is that the the work around the medicine
is called integration
right they get a broad sense and so
um talk therapy is one of the best forms
of integration
like excuse me meditation is a great
form of integration
talk therapy bodywork there's
emdr there's so many therapeutic
modalities
and i started talk therapy er
man i'm 45 so about 10 years ago i went
to psychoanalysis i think i started
about 35
34 35 psychoanalysis i went four
times a week for four years so like
i i exhausted talk therapy in my life
um like i and talk therapy is amazing
at getting giving you a map to your
emotions and
in your brain and understanding
what like what is the map of your brain
but it's sort of like if you have a map
of manhattan
it's useful but it's it's not at all
like walking the streets of manhattan
right now
a map if you want to walk the streets of
manhattan and get anywhere you kind of
need a map
right so like you need both walking the
streets are important
and having a map is important but
they're not the same thing and so
talk therapy gave me a map but it was
psychedelic medicine that really broke
me open and helped me start to
feel i i really couldn't i was
completely almost completely
disconnected from my emotions and myself
and then i mean i wrote a huge article
about this on medium about
it's like obnoxiously long ten thousand
words or something
about my first two mdma experiences
which was about two and a half years ago
and um those were the most pivotal
things i've ever done in my life like
mdma therapy especially i didn't
realize how disconnected i was and how
deeply i could feel and how
much emotion i had and how much trauma i
had
unprocessed god i had so much michaela
and it's like i understood it
intellectually like i i got it all
like yeah my parents you know kind of
were narcissistic and abandoned me a lot
of ways and i felt
lonely and i felt sad and disconnected
as a kid like i got it all
intellectually
two and a half years of deep psychedelic
therapy with
mdma with psilocybin at times with lsd
at times with ketamine at times with
even dmt
now at times um none of them
have shown me anything i didn't know
what they've all about about myself and
my own trauma right
what they've all done is helped me get
into it
and feel those emotions and connect with
them
and and then like that's but that's the
work i mean that's what all
therapy is is about understanding what
you're feeling
feeling it and then um letting those
feelings go
right uh that's what i've been doing the
last
if i hadn't done the work i did up to
meeting my wife was crucial
to getting to a place where the type of
woman i want because i wanted a badass
baller woman
and she wouldn't have wanted me like the
way i was when i came out of the frat
tire days because i
was awesome but also honestly broken in
a lot of ways
and uh and the woman i wanted to marry
wouldn't have wanted that and nor should
she
and so i had to do enough work to get
myself to the place where it's like okay
i'm the type of guy
that the woman i want wants to marry and
then i met her almost immediately it was
pretty magical actually
and then um then we've now we've grown
immensely together
right like and she's done her work as
well and
and it's been incredible uh and then you
know the kids god man if i hadn't done
this work i would have been
i would have been a better parent than
my parents but not much
and now it's like it's funny i was
saying this the other day um
i feel like my kids have taught me how
to love myself you know
not intentionally but like it's like
every
issue i have and every problem i have i
see reflected in them
and then i have to face it in a way that
it's like i can't fool myself about it
it's like oh [ __ ]
my son is calling himself stupid he did
not
like that's not that's coming from me
and my wife like it's coming from us
so we and what i can't say like if i
tell him
that's wrong that's not he's not gonna
listen he's not gonna listen to what i
say he's going to watch what i do and
reflect who i am and so i've got to
become a better person
if i want to be a better dad and so no
psychological therapy without that
nothing none of my company my company is
awesome and huge
and the only reason is because the work
i've done there
right um like i stepped aside a ceo when
we got to a certain size hired a
professional
who's a complete badass and the reason
that we've grown
immensely thousands of percent or
whatever
uh it's like everything i have good in
my life is because of the therapeutic
work i've done
and most of that is was unlocked by
psychedelics okay that's quite a quite a
selling point
i've talked to i've talked to a lot of
people i'm like i said a huge proponent
of
particularly what's been beneficial to
me is psilocybin i think over
i although i haven't done anything in
like a
therapeutic setting yeah did you manage
to go see somebody who did this
professional oh yeah of course of course
so i'm it's so funny
people i never i swear to god i had
never done drugs
at all that does surprise me after
reading the book never
well but if you read all the books
there's nothing in there about it it's
all alcohol
and it's all being an idiot and and uh
women right
it's like those were my vices never
drugs
i'll admit i was definitely um i
definitely fell victim to the nancy
reagan
uh dare you know uh propaganda like uh
and growing up the only people who did
drugs around me were losers
and so my association with drugs was
definitely well that's what losers do
right um i didn't understand them as
medicine right i didn't understand the
history of them
you know shamanic history i didn't
understand any of that and then
i saw a few of my friends one a couple
whom are very famous do this years
before
me and i saw the changes in them i was
like oh wow
and then like i saw a close friend of
mine do it and i was like
okay like now i get it i see it i get it
and so um i found i'm i got lucky um
one of the best guy mdma guys in america
did a book with my company
and so i got connected to her right the
book's called trust her under receive
and it you know her name her author name
is anne other like another
right um that's obviously a fake name
for her
because she's like a practicing
psychotherapist and she's like very well
known in her community what but she's
been doing this for like 20 years
sitting for people she's amazing
and so um she was my guide and she was
she was
like you could not have scripted a
better
person to be a guy like it was like
she like what yoda is to luke she was to
to me and for hundreds of other people
right
and so um and then she has trained a
bunch of other guys and so
i got connected into her and then i
started donating to maps you know the
organization that that is kind of
spearheading
do you know maps at all no i haven't
heard them okay so maps in america maps
is the organization that is
uh spearheading the legalization of
psychedelics as they're i should know
that yeah so rick doblin who you might
have heard of his name is the guy who
started that
okay so rick that's his organization and
right now mdma is in stage
the final stages of clinical trials
they're called
stage three second phase trials to be
legal
um because there's been a bunch of
studies uh over the last
five years the uh mdma
has mainly on people with treatment
resistant ptsd so like war veterans and
rape victims people who for whom no
other treatment has worked
something like 60 to 80 percent of them
are cured after something like three
sessions of mdma
cured as in they don't meet the clinical
diagnosis for ptsd anymore
not just helped like this is astounding
this is arguably the greatest
results ever in the history of
psychiatric medicine
right psychiatric meds certainly don't
work like that
that's true that is definitely true
so like uh um they're on track to be
legalized in 2022 or 2023
uh in america they are already received
compassionate care designation and
they're pretty fast-tracked
yeah okay i didn't know that yeah it uh
probably
looks like actually australia february
third
may legalize it may change the the uh
scheduling
of mdma and psilocybin to make them
prescribable if australia does it i
think the rest of the world
is real yeah yeah and so um yeah so so
there are
uh anyway so i got plugged into maps and
um
through maps uh and through people that
work with maps i met other people who
you know
they're doing legal sort of like
university studies so like
they're not helping me right like rick's
like listen i can't get you into a study
like it's we got to do it the right way
um uh but like
they know people um who know people so
to speak and so like i met some other
guides and there's a not a massive there
are quite a few guys especially in
america who have been
helping people with this for years like
either ayahuasca
or dmt or 5muodmt or psilocybin
or lsd or mdma
there are people who have been
essentially pioneers who've been holding
the torch lit
during the dark periods of the 70s 80s
and 90s
and thank god they did because like
it's been so game changing for me and i
wrote about this and it's so funny
like i i know a lot of famous people
really famous people who way more famous
than me who are doing this
and seeing amazing results and changing
their lives and they're all afraid to
talk about it
at first i was very judgmental of them
i'm like what the [ __ ] man like
i'm still judgmental i i won't say their
names but like
all people that you would be super
excited to have on your podcast right
big names and then i realized all right
my judgment's my issue
they have their own reasons that's fine
i'm going to talk about it because
i can't i couldn't look myself in the
mirror yeah
if i didn't share this um uh and
yes it's a risk i i would judge the risk
and was willing to take it
but the hard part was uh i didn't what i
didn't anticipate and i should have i
just didn't think about
this i think i had i don't know how many
thousands of people email me after i
wrote the piece about my mdma therapy
asking me for a referral to a guide oh
yeah that's the main
yeah and i was like oh no i hadn't like
like a fool i hadn't anticipated this
right
and so like uh but i was like listen
i have put this into the world i felt
i'm not saying i did or i didn't
i felt i had a responsibility to help
them so now i wasn't going to become a
guide like
there's a certain mindset that i think
becomes great guides i don't think i
have it you know i'd be like come on
like let's go
you need more mdma let's heal hurry up
like i would be the total wrong person
but um this isn't as bad as the last
client you should have
heard his story right exactly oh yeah
stop crying buddy come on let's go buck
out yeah i'd be a terrible terrible
indiana guy
because they're all so gentle and calm
and it's like they have this energy
about them that since
all of the ones i've met are pretty
amazing
so what i did was i got plugged i made
in a serious effort to
find the nodes of underground guides in
america and because i have enough famous
friends and enough connected friends
i found most of them or at least a lot
of them and then i
reached out to as many as i could and i
said hey listen are you willing to take
blind referrals you know i was very
clear like all of them were like yeah
once i get to know you of course anyone
you know and trust
and i'm like no no you don't understand
i have a lot of people emailing me that
i
they could be the copiest cops on in cop
land i have no idea who they are
um and so like if i get a bad feeling i
won't but if they seem like a normal
person and they have like a linkedin and
stuff
are you willing to take referrals and
most guys were like absolutely not
of course and i get it and i was like
yeah i totally get it right
i found two who were both they're both
like no i trust my gut
sure you can send me anyone you want and
i'm like okay
and so those two guys have probably both
of them i've
i've sent well into the multiple
hundreds of people um
and so like uh because it's like i just
like i was like how do i how do i talk
about this and then not
how do i do it not talk about it and
then how do i talk about it and not at
least
figure something out for these people
right
and it's been actually kind of insane
because the ripple effect i've seen
a bunch of the people that i sent right
i just send them like here's
i don't connect them i just say here's
this person's email
here's the the email to send the code
word tell them you're from me
and then it's on them i don't follow up
it's nothing like i don't take a
referral fee i don't make any money on
this it's just whatever
so many of those people have come back
to me now and uh
like they're doing books they're
starting organizations
they've become guides like they've done
a bunch of their own work and they got
went and trained to become one from
usually from the people i refer them to
um it's incredible the the the change
i think this is going to sweep there's
so much
whatever you want to call it bad news in
the world this is one of those things
that not a lot of people are talking
about but i think is going we're going
to look back on
like the way we look back on penicillin
you know or the way we look back on the
abolition of slavery
i think we're going to look back on this
psychedelic medicine revolution
as one of the most important moments in
human history
um because i like as a civilization i
think we're just in all
credibly traumatized and incredibly
disconnected from ourselves
and i've never found a tool and i've
tried every
everything never found a tool like this
you know it's
though i have the life i have and i am
the person i am because i started
i did everything else around it right i
did all the other work like if you think
that any of these if you think mushrooms
are a magic pill you take some mushrooms
everything's great in your life then
you're in for a
very i always tell people things will
get way harder before they get easier
like this is
you are you are going into the dark cave
that you
fear to enter when you are taking
psychedelics but the point is
it helps you come out the other side too
if you're willing to do the work but
you've got to do the work
and the people that are i mean the
changes i've seen with my friends and
with even all these other people
i don't know like it's hard to overstate
it you know like
every single person that i know is like
yeah it's the most important thing i've
ever done in my life
yeah yeah it's funny if you haven't done
any and you listen to somebody talk
about them and they say it was
it was my number one life-changing
experience it was like
that's odd and it's very difficult to
understand if you haven't tried it
i found that the most helpful it's only
helpful for me
if i'm in a place where i'm really open
to
improving or learning about my flaws if
i'm open to learning about my flaws and
then changing them then i have a good
experience but if i
try and use them to do the work then i
don't have a good experience
no yeah no no so you've actually never
done you do it just yourself or with
friends or whatever you don't do with a
guide in a guided setting
no i don't trust people in general like
i've gone to so i
i did therapy for a while and i had such
terrible
like i think especially for talk therapy
you really need to find a
smart person oh of course and i didn't
have any therapists that were
good so um like all the work i've done
was myself
for sure oh my yeah no so i've done a
few sessions
myself um they weren't useless
but they were nothing like getting a
good
therapist right in the back i haven't
found one
uh so the best guides um uh that i
uh have dealt with don't actually do a
whole lot of talking
yeah that's yeah that's good they they
create this spit
first off feeling safe with someone is a
huge
like that's not a small thing right and
so the best guys i know get to know you
ahead of time
right understand you and then that
you know you come into their space and
then their space is always you know
beautiful and manicured and like safe
and it feels great
and then they like basically what
they're doing is putting a cocoon of
safety around you and telling you in
when you're on this medicine in this
space nothing outside of you can come in
i'm protecting you you're safe and then
if you
need me you can call me in or talk
you know like we can talk you can if you
need me to hold your hand or whatever i
can
do that but if you don't that's okay too
i'll be here protecting you
right and that is like a v for that's
not all medicines right like ayahuasca
it's very interactive with the the um
the facilitator right
but for mdma especially mdma
the best facilitators do almost nothing
during the session um it's all before
and after
right so before they help you build
trust in them and help you understand
what's coming
and then after they help you integrate
it and help you understand
what happened and how to er how to
how to process it right because like if
you
if you've never done that and you do it
and all of a sudden all these
these memories come up or all this
trauma comes up it's like what do you do
then right and so that's integration
work and so the good ones help you with
that too
and that's what's super super key is
understanding that but
it's so funny it's like one of the guys
that i refer people to
she's uh had no psychological training
nothing like that at all but she is one
of those people that when you meet her
it's like she's so open and so
emotionally connected connect she's such
an
empath that you just feel amazing with
her right and it's so funny that like
i've done a bunch like i know i mean i
spent so much time in therapy i can out
therapy most therapists by far
like easily like i can therapy around
them like i can
i can tie them into knots it's rare for
me to find someone
uh who can even come and i'm not saying
this arrogantly you're probably very
smart too that's why you couldn't find a
therapist to deal with it
i had to go to 20 therapists before i
found it okay see i didn't try that hard
i gave up i was like this is bad bad bad
bad bad
this is harmful i'm done no kayla you
gotta think of it like dating
it really is like dating like it truly
is like i don't know if like if you
your husband is one of the first people
you met but my wife was definitely
not the first woman i met and so
therapists are the same way
like i i went to 10 psychoanalysts or 10
therapists
and then what i eventually realized is i
have to go to the the therapist
for therapists i have to go to the
teacher of therapists and so i
the ones that i thought were half decent
i asked them who
trained them i'm dead serious and so i
found one woman who's in texas
who she is like one of the main
psychoanalysis trainers and one of the
main psychoanalysts
for analysts like like she's the person
they go to
and i'm like okay she's going to be able
to
hold my my weight and and be able to
to hit strength to strength and she was
she was
she was exactly who i needed she was
smart enough
everything i tried all my tricks all my
traps all my
she was able to meet them head-on right
and and not
back down it was like okay that's what i
needed then
but then like for for psychedelic
medicine it's the opposite like i need
someone i don't need someone
skilled in the brain i need someone
who's deeply empathic
who's in touch with themselves and can
be in touch with me
when i need it and help me navigate my
emotions
it is um it's the difference between
chicken [ __ ] and chicken salad mckayla
truly doing it without
without a guide and with a guide um it's
so so because a great guide it's like
it's like you can imagine watching a
movie without sound
you can kind of figure out what's going
on in most movies right you might even
enjoy it
but if you hear the sound it's like oh
now i understand all the context
that really is kind of the difference
having a great guide
gives you the sound of the subtitle or
watching a foreign film
a great guide gives you the subtitles
that's what they're about
okay well i'm sold i know that they do i
haven't heard of any of these type of
therapies around at least
in canada they probably exist
underground and i just haven't looked
into it
i know that they they do ketamine
therapy
yeah that's legal ketamine's legal and
then psilocybin is a
is about to become legal in canada i'm
pretty sure there's a lot you can get
micro dose
you can get by micro dosing amounts in
in grams so it's legal it's just like
the dosage is micro dose but here's five
grams
okay yeah i mean field trip is a company
that that
i know real well they're in canada
they're they have clinics and stuff and
there's a couple of others
in canada uh you're in toronto yeah
yeah so um
you can find people okay if you want
help you you know someone who can i want
help so
all right that sounds that sounds good
um okay i want to finish off with this
is in an entirely different
direction again um you have a you have a
family you have a whole bunch of kids
you're you're aiming for four um how do
you
balance with your wife because i did it
like did a little background digging and
i know your wife is either
she's at the top of a business somewhere
she owns a couple businesses yeah she
owns a couple of businesses
yeah so how do you guys manage having
three kids and
owning businesses yeah so it's it's
very difficult uh no one teaches you how
to do this
no and so no really it's it's a heart
she's a nurse practitioner she has a
medical practice and she also has a
training uh company for nurse
practitioners
so she actually has two companies um and
and then i have my own company right so
which is huge and so it was
what we had to do so like instead i
won't tell you the whole navi how we
navigated all of it
but here's what we got to we realized
the first thing
and this was really hard for her was
we have to take care of ourselves first
right and so we have to make a priority
of taking and she especially
um uh as a woman like found it
psychologically very difficult to put
herself first
right but like the thing i had to help
her understand was that she is the
center of the family right
especially with young kids like for
i don't care how great of a dad you are
uh but
the center of a young child's life is
always the mom right dad might be one a
or one b but mom is one a and so and
there's nothing wrong with that's the
way it should be and then as they grow
and mature then data
can become more and more important right
but um and that's exactly how it's
worked my six year old now is like very
close six and a half year old very close
to me
uh and like his world is spreading but
and so
she so because she understood that she
was the center of the family she's an
amazing mother
but the way she interpreted being a
great mother was essentially
destroying herself like she had to
sacrifice herself
to her family and her children and her
business yeah and it got to a point
where she was breaking
physically mentally everything socially
spiritually and i was like honey this
isn't gonna work
and so like i like we used to have
michaela you wouldn't believe the
arguments
i thought we were crazy we would have
arguments i would be like
i would be mad at her because she
wouldn't spend money
for a maid i'm like and she would like
i'll be arguing with me and i'm like
how is our argument where i'm telling
you to spend more money
to do less work and you're arguing that
that's wrong like i was like how does
this make sense
and so like she had a very that that
just it was a very
self-sacrificial mindset and a very
middle-class mindset like i have to do
everything
people can't do things for me i've
actually had that argument i've had that
argument a couple of weeks ago with my
husband
same same type of thing like right and
then yeah anyway continue
so so eventually she she had to suffer
enough where she realized it wasn't
going to work anymore
and so then um like we hired a maid and
then we got a household manager
and it really was an uh like i had to
get her used to the idea
that um the only way you can show up
if you actually love your me and our
children the only way you can
show up as a great wife and mother is to
take care of yourself first to put
yourself
first and so she had to emotionally
accept that
and then she had to really understand
what that looked like on a day-to-day
practice
right and she's worked really hard at
that and she's gotten great at that
right and then um i had the opposite
or not the opposite but i had a
different issue like i i was very
supportive of her and that sort of stuff
but then like i was i just there were a
lot of things i didn't think about
because i
i'm an only child and i'd been alone for
so long
i dated a lot of girls whatever but i'd
never really truly been in a committed
union type situation and so i had to get
there were just
worlds i didn't understand right like i
didn't understand
like oh you're thinking about it this
way it was just
i had never thought of that so i had to
understand yeah
i had to understand her minds she had to
learn to put herself
first i had to learn to live in a
interdependent
group right and then once we kind of
learn those things
then it really became a a a matter of
we spend money to buy time
right so like we not only do we have a
maid we have
a uh full-time household manager because
if we have two cups what does that mean
okay so my wife doesn't do laundry
uh she doesn't she doesn't do any of the
neither do i
i'm not doing the [ __ ] domestic
chores i'm sorry my time's too valuable
she used to think that she had to do
that that was like her job as a woman to
do that
and not in a sexist way it was just if i
love my family then i'm washing their
clothes and if i'm not washing their
clothes
that makes me a bad person right and so
once she deprogrammed that
and realized that wasn't true at all
that she could pay someone to do that
and still love her family
so we have like we don't she just works
on
her businesses and that way she frees up
time work-wise
she teaches a ton of time to do herself
stuff
and family stuff and then we re like we
sit down
on a routine basis what do we want from
our lives
how do we structure our lives so we have
that right and then who's the best
person to be doing these things she used
to think how do i do [ __ ]
how do i get the laundry done and cook
dinner and this
and that i'm like no no who's gonna do
the laundry
who's gonna i like cooking so we ended
up that became mine but i don't want to
prep and do dishes
so our household manager preps the food
during the day and then does the dishes
the next morning like
if you came into our house for dinner
you'd be like oh you guys cook amazing
stuff and then by the end you just see
all the dishes piled in the sink and we
don't touch them they'd be there in the
morning
household manager shows up takes the
kids to school comes back cleans all
that
gets everything ready for the next day
so we like
from our kids experience we're extremely
involved parents like
we either she or i pick them up from
school every day
we make their food from four o'clock to
seven o'clock uh
they're like we don't do anything but
engage with them and then
uh 6 30 a.m to 8 30 a.m so the times
they're home
and weekends we're fully engaged but
all of the [ __ ] chores you know we
use ins we don't go
shopping instacart delivers everything
like we don't go to stores
amazon unless we want to unless going to
the store is a thing we want to do
with our family because it's sometimes
fun to the whole family goes to whole
foods or whatever
but we we really think about what do we
want our life to be
and then we make our life that usually
by
trading money for time does that make
sense
that was a solid answer like one of the
problems
i've been having is so i have a daughter
she's
three and a half um and we're gonna have
another kid
and two's perfect i'll just tell you two
is the perfect number
you're going to four yeah we are because
once you get past two it's just [ __ ]
bedlam it doesn't matter how many you
have
like two with two you can do man-to-man
defense like if we stopped at two we'd
be in such an easy phase right now
like i'm not saying uh don't have three
or four
but i'm just saying two is a really
really good number
says the guy going on four yeah i don't
think i'm gonna end up stopping it too
but it makes it really difficult because
i've had the same thing i i don't have
enough time
if i lived by myself and and didn't
didn't have anything else other than
work right i have so much
and it's great right i have a lot of
opportunity and i want to take advantage
of it i'm entrepreneurial
and it's and then i have this guilt all
the time because i have the same
i need to be cleaning and cooking and
doing laundry and then the house and i
hate when things are messy
and the house is always kind of messy
because oh wait until you have enough
time oh yeah i can't imagine because
this is
one right and like how do you make so
much of a mess
right um and then i had a conversation
with andre a couple weeks ago and he was
like we need to hire
like you're you're making money and
you're wasting your time and you're
stressed out and you're mad at me
and i was just like yeah okay i guess
that makes sense
yeah no it is it was really hard for me
to understand this because
most guys don't have this mindset but
they're
almost every successful woman i have has
this like this almost
shame that she's not super mom
right like my wife felt like if she
wasn't super
mom then she was a bad person like she
wasn't enough
and it was kind of like i told you like
even though she has two businesses
right and i'm like baby like
i i could not have been more supportive
of like i'm like do you want to be a
stay-at-home mom
i would love that do you want to have
multiple businesses and be a rockstar
entrepreneur i would also love that
both of them are great to me truly
because i make enough money it doesn't
matter to me
like i just want you so i tell her i
want you to do the things that make you
happy
in a way that's beneficial for the whole
family
right and it can be anything you truly
get like i'm like you're lucky enough
that with me
you can pick you don't have to do any of
this you just
just do the things that make sense it
and and she
she all this pressure was like it was
like
i hate to say societal pressure but
really this is kind of societal
no it really like women have this
feeling at least my wife and other
successful women i know that like if
they aren't super mom they're evil
supermom doesn't exist
that no seriously that that doesn't
there's no such thing as a woman who
does it all
and is all things to all people without
being nothing for herself
yeah like that's it she like my wife was
an empty broken
hull of a human when she was trying to
be all things to all people
and when she let that go that's not good
for your kids either right
it's not good for me for her for us for
anyone like
like it was it was awful it was like it
was the worst
and like she even she knew it and
finally she got reached her breaking
point and she was
able to let that stuff go and realize
oh if i the thing i need to do is take
care of my
michaela one time i literally i i
got her a weekend at an amazing resort
like two hours from austin where we live
and like i'm like i got the kids taken
care i'm going to be here
i got help like her mom uh was in town
so it's like who's like
kids love granny and i get along amazing
with her mom so i was like we got the
kids
like you need to leave and like and she
like almost
couldn't leave when it was time to leave
and it was like
and i'm like turn off your phone she
kept texting i'm like literally i'm
gonna block you from my phone you don't
get to
think about anything here for the next
two days
like you need to go think about yourself
because she was in such an amped up
state of like i have to be on top of all
these things it was like she was
addicted to that right
and then finally that weekend plus a few
other real trigger points
she realized all that sort of stuff and
then she let that go and then it was
just a discussion it was really
i'm telling it's so weird i have this
book on my desk i'm telling you
like i didn't write this my name's none
on it but who not how was the one of the
things that really
that idea did it's i've been in dan
sullivan's group for a while
and that was the the sort of thing i was
like this is the thing you need to
really
yeah understand it's a whole idea of
like
who can i get to do this with me instead
or for me
instead of how do i do it like a book we
started with scribe right
most people's question is how do i write
a book the better question is
who do i get to help me write my book
like because i mean being a writer is
like a professional job right
like why would you expect to be able to
do that yourself
hire someone and then how whatever level
you want help
you can get a little bit of help for a
couple thousand dollars in coaching you
can get
all the greatest writers that exist with
the best publishing stuff for into the
six figures
or anything in between then it's just a
question of how much is my time worth
how much can i afford what's the
investment worth to me etc etc etc right
but it's the mindset shift of i don't
have to do
everything and be everything to all
people i'm okay with who i
am which is like it gets back again that
ties into therapy the psychedelic thing
i mean that was
that's the thing i'm still working
through is like
self-love and feeling okay with who you
are
[ __ ] about a struggle yeah well that is
a struggle it's also
it's also i think more of a struggle for
people who
um at least are more conscientious or
are trying to accomplish more because
there's always that underlying i'm not
doing well enough and
part of that is what makes you more
successful because you keep pushing
right if you're if you're you want to be
okay with yourself but if you're
so okay even if you really shouldn't be
then you might be feeling better but
you're not going to be accomplishing
what you could
yeah so that is a whole separate
question right
like the it's one of those things where
it's like um if you're worried that
you're a sociopath you're normal
certainly not
right yeah okay well it's the same thing
if you're worried
that you're being too lazy and not
accomplishing anything yeah there's no
[ __ ] way
that's true yeah it's a good thing to
remember
okay well i have to let you go but that
was
that was very entertaining thank you so
much for coming on of course
yeah and uh i'll touch base after the
podcast and get some hookups
hopefully any time
you